you
cussing
music
please
You
Hello my sweet snowberries. Hi.
Hello. Hello.
I hope that you are doing well today.
I have a bit of problems with my throat.
So if I don't speak as much as I usually do during my ASMR streams, that's why then on top of that I also have a migraine as well.
I take some painkillers before the stream but they still didn't kick in yet.
So sorry in advance if I'm not at my best performance today.
I hope you can understand.
Feel free to end stream really if it's too much. Yeah I will but for now I'm completely okay.
I miss you a lot and I really want to spend some time together.
Thank you.
So yesterday, as some of you know, I kind of had a day for disconnecting from you.
From what I do and from breathing anything and from social media etc.
And I'll be honest, it was so fucking difficult.
It was like really really difficult.
I legitimately felt like a physical feeling in my chest.
My chest felt really tight the whole day because I kept wanting to read everything and respond to things and all of that.
So it was really more difficult than I thought it would be.
And that's kind of scary because it literally felt like how people describe it when you're addicted to something.
And then you try to stop doing it and you just have the strongest urges to do it.
And you have to basically restrain yourself and it takes so much control and effort to do that.
With that being said, I don't think you realized actually what happened yesterday.
Yes, I did disconnect from everything.
However, I actually ended up not going outside because I was so sleepy and tired
that I ended up just like sleeping pretty much the whole day.
So basically what happened is I woke up.
I was awake for like a little bit, got sleepy, went back to sleep, woke up again.
I had lunch, watched some videos, felt sleepy again, went back to sleep again until like 6pm.
Like no joke, I woke up at like 6pm.
I was so sleepy, like really really sleepy.
And so when I woke up at like 6pm I was like fuck, I'm so tired.
Like I really really don't want to go anywhere.
So I just, yeah, yesterday was just me just sleeping pretty much.
I didn't go outside.
But I actually did go outside today because I still wanted to go outside like I promised myself.
So I did go outside and I just walked around and just breathed some nice fresh air.
The weather was really nice.
It was like warm but not overbearing, you know.
There was like a nice wind.
And actually in the middle of it it started raining really hard, like out of nowhere.
And everyone was like surprised because on the weather forecast it was not supposed to rain today.
But it did.
But it was really refreshing because I could smell, you know, that good scent of the rain.
So it was like, but fresh rain, scent.
It was extremely nice and refreshing.
And then I went to a store just to see if there's anything I need or if there's any like stuff that I could like maybe use for ASMR triggers.
And it's pretty crazy but when I was there, there was a song that started playing.
And the beginning of that song sounded a lot like fade into you, the song that I was singing at the karaoke.
So when I heard like the first few seconds of the melody, like I instantly like thought about, you know, the karaoke night we had.
And my heart like skipped a beat, you know.
And then, and not after that, they played Braining Man.
Like I'm not fucking kidding, they played Braining Man.
And I was like, no fucking way, no fucking way.
I thought it was really crazy because you know, I go outside to disconnect from you, right?
And not think about any of this.
But then even when I go outside, you know, to distract myself, there's things that remind me of you.
Like the songs from the karaoke that started playing and like instantly like my brain went, what the fuck?
Like no, no, no way that happened.
And I instantly, you know, smiled and remembered how amazing the karaoke was and how much fun I had.
I also ordered some food to get home with me.
It was like this really, really good like dish salad that had like grilled vegetables and some lettuce and like small baby potatoes.
It was so freaking good, holy fuck.
Like I didn't not expect it to taste that good, but it was really, really fucking good.
I think I think it had like red peppers in it, eggplant, some lettuce and some, I don't know what else was there.
There were more stuff, but I don't remember the name of it, but anyways, it tasted really, really, really good as the point.
So I was really happy that I got that.
So when I was at the store, I bought like this lollipop chupa chups.
This is a lollipop candy.
I bought it because when I was a kid, I remember I used to really love these and I haven't had it since then, pretty much.
So I thought I could buy it and maybe I'll use it too for some of my smart triggers, possibly.
The flavor is strawberry.
And then I bought like this squishy stress toy, I guess.
It's very like bright pink, and it has like a really stupid and silly face.
And I thought maybe I could use it as an ASMR trigger, but to be fair, I don't know how good of a sound it makes.
It actually sounds pretty nice.
I'm glad to hear that, because the thing is, it was inside like a packaging.
So it was hard for me to figure out exactly what it's going to sound like outside of it, but it's a squishy toy, so I thought maybe it would make good sounds.
I also have bubble wrap.
I remember that someone has requested bubble wrap as an ASMR trigger, so today's your lucky day, because they have some bubble wrap.
The bubble wrap makes really, really good sounds, really tingly ones, I think.
So I have a feeling most of you would probably enjoy it.
Okay, let me bring the bubble wrap.
I can't wait to talk.
Right, it sounds so good, doesn't it?
I think bubble wrap makes really good sounds.
I think a decent bubble wrap makes a lot of sounds.
I'm kicking and thinking of forgetting a text from why is he saying this song remind me of you and the speaker explodes with a training man.
Thank you.
Super.
Packaging my tea sands up to ship them to your address.
Okay, real.
Thank you.
I'm here.
That's why I need to wrap you in bubble wrap so I can be shipped to your address.
Okay.
I love pulling you together like a ship.
I love you.
Okay.
Touch.
I hope it's okay with you.
It'll be right back.
Okay, I need to.
I need to be super super fat.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
I love you.
Take it.
Okay.
So I see how if you're playing the game again, huh?
I'm actually wearing black panties today.
And thank you for all the welcome back.
Okay.
I love you, I love you, I love you, I love you.
I love you
Scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch.
Scratch, scratch.
ca-chis-chis, ca-chis-chis
ca-chis-chis, ca-chis-chis, ca-chis-chis
Plus six
a-side-butt-load
a-side-but-load
outside
oh my god, I can't... I can't find the juice... I can't find the juice
somber, thank you so much for joining funpush it, I love
you
how do you come up with these triggers?
I just look around the house and see if there's anything I can make good sounds with
that's pretty much all it is
make good choices, this is super comfy, yay, thank you
I try my best to find the triggers every time there's an ASMR stream
can we get something in Russian too? depends, like what?
I would say that, but my parents hooked my thoughts
so how about I say that in the member stream? would that be okay?
I could say that in a member stream tomorrow, but I can still say I love you in Russian
I love you
very much
what do you mean discovered? they know
what do you mean oof? they support me, they're very sweet about it
so they approve of your misters, I mean I think they would prefer if I have one mister
but
hello Kevin, thank you for the membership, welcome
I can't, you always make me laugh, you're so funny
for 100 people turning up to your brand's house to ask permission to marry you
imagine, oh my god, my dad would be like, what the fuck, who are these people?
fucking kicks you down the fucking stairs, punches you
oh my god, now we'd win
my dad is super nice, he's really sweet, he's not much of a talker and he looks very serious but he's a good person
it's good to be an interesting family for you
I don't think that would be enough space for all of you to be honest, they live like in a really really small apartment
basement, they don't have a basement
can I just hang out on the porch with Bob up here while the other guy sits right there
I mean, I suppose if you get to talk to him then maybe your chance is higher
than if you spend it fighting with others
like if you drink a beer with him or something like that then he would enjoy that
I don't drink though, well, if you don't drink, I don't know how you're gonna bond with my dad to be honest
oh my god, pure and fraught, I fucking can't
rogue Robin, thank you so much for the membership, welcome in
can I live in the fridge?
no
I can take him to dinner and go fishing
fishing, he would love the heck out of that, my dad actually loves fishing
sometimes he goes on the weekends fishing with his friends
and then he comes back home and cooks the fish that he got for my mom
and it always makes her extremely happy, I think it's super sweet
ah
the real question is if Papa Bear is single, what the fuck, no
my parents are married for like 25 years, they are very much happily married
they're definitely not single, happily married for 25 years
no, there's no chance, shut up, I love my parents' relationship and their marriage
they're the only reason that I have hope that marriages can work and that you can be married for so long
and still show affection to each other and still do nice gestures for each other
you know, not to have this basically dead relationship just because you're married
so they're literally the reason that I still believe that it's possible to have a really good and healthy marriage
like, whenever it's her anniversary or her birthday, my dad always buys her either jewelry or some flowers and stuff like that
and you know, when he goes fishing, he really likes to cook the fish that he gets for her
and they love traveling as well, which is another thing that I think is super cute
at least once a year they go travel somewhere around the world and you know, enjoy their life to the best together and make memories
so, yeah, I really love the relationship that my parents have and they would be like the perfect example for, you know, a good, healthy and loving marriage
do they always travel together?
yes, always
like, a couple of months ago, it was my dad's birthday
and my mom basically planned a trip to Austria with him
and I actually took a train to Austria so that I could see my dad and celebrate his birthday together with him
so, yeah
I love their relationship
their relationship
and I love them in general
they have always been very sweet and supportive of me, always loving and I really can't say enough good things about my mom and dad
both very amazing people
and my grandparents
my grandparents have been married for like 60 years
would have been longer if he didn't pass away
but basically they had like, you know, a really good relationship as well
and the way that they met is actually a crazy story
if you want, I'll tell you like, the crazy story about my grandma and grandpa got together
when my mom told me the story, it was like, holy shit, that's crazy
so basically, so back story, my grandpa was actually already engaged
and he was actually supposed to have a wedding and marry someone
and just one day, when he was at the train station
my grandma just casually walked out of that train
and he saw her and he just like, you know, like instantly knew that she's the one
like, he saw her and he knew that she's the one
and he ended up cancelling the wedding
and, you know, tried to get my grandma's attention
and, you know, get her and he did
and they've had a really amazing relationship
and they have been married for 60 years
freaking 60 years, you know
so, yeah, it's like, sometimes, sometimes, like, he just knew, you know, like, he saw her
and he instantly knew that, yes, this is my person, you know, this is the person that
I'm gonna spend the rest of my life with and he just did everything he could
to, you know, get together with her
and they ended up getting married and being married for 60 years
so, yeah, that's the story of how my grandparents got together
so
you're not a feminist, you're just
thank you
you
you know how our story so gets your mother was made for with lots of this
I fucking can't, but there will be no kids
no kids, because I don't want kids
I am the kid
I respect them
I
myself can't just while making certain comments on some of your friends now
don't be it
they, they don't know English really, like, barely anything
that's fine
so good, that's
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
so easy
I mean, if
that's the idea
shh
h h h
It's just...
La la la la la la la
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
What is this?
I just can't stop
It's great love
It's great love for chance
I lost focus so much
labour
shh shh shh shh shh shh shh shh alcohol
Ma shhhhhh
shhhhh
olol orange
shhhche
orange
If you can not open your mouth like this,
open your mouth, open, open,
Come on.
Hey yuppies.
I want you to close your mouth笑 sh** wine sh**.
Hey yuppies, yuppies, yuppies, yuppies.
Chיל pierceds h**k.
It is a better way to apply blush, so feel right in the nuts.
I don't like to hug, I don't like to hug daddy.
I don't like to hug daddy, I don't like to hug him.
I don't like to hug daddy, I don't like to hug daddy, I don't like to hug daddy.
I don't like to hug, I don't like to hug daddy, I don't like to hug mommy, I don't like to hug my daddy.
I can't focus on you, I can't focus on you, because I love you so much.
I love you so much, I love you so much.
I love you so much.
Stupid migraine.
I need forehead massage from Dada.
So that's where I go for care on my forehead.
I'm supposed to show you what massage is.
I love you so much, I love you so much.
I love you so much.
I actually wanted to try something today.
I wanted to see if me putting a blanket on this radio will make some confi sounds that maybe sound like waves or the sea.
So let me know what you think.
If you don't think it sounds all that great, I'll stop doing it.
If you like it, let me know.
I love you so much.
Cover your eyes with a blanket.
My passion makes some nice sounds.
I love you so much.
I love all my stomach noises on the way.